(Robot whirring)
- My name is Zoe Dingeman.
I play football for Notre Dame.
(Suspenseful music)
Robotic football.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] At the
University of Notre Dame,
football is a big deal.
In the basement halls of
the engineering school,
a group of students are
turning their beloved
sport into science.
(upbeat music)
- The Robotic Football
Club is an engineering club
with students from a variety of different
engineering majors that work together
to design, build, fabricate,
and play with robots.
(chattering)
- You may not think it,
but robotic football
actually is a lot like real football.
Our goal in this club is to
make the game as comparable
to human football as possible.
We have, for example, a
quarterback that can throw a ball.
We have wide receivers
that can catch the ball.
We have offensive linemen,
defensive linemen.
Offensive linemen on the kickoff team,
Connor and Michelle, I
want you hitting people
on the kickoff.
Robotic football is
definitely a contact sport.
You're trying to hit
the other team's robots
as hard as you can,
and so you need to build
designs that are robust
that can handle that sort of stress
that they're constantly placed under.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] From it's
founding six years ago,
the club's roster now boasts
20 robot football players
at a variety of positions, all controlled
and driven by 35 humans on the sideline.
- [Zoe] This is RPM, it's
our first-string quarterback
and it's a really interesting robot.
It uses semi-autonomous
features to scan the field
and find the receiver
that it'd like to pass to.
Once it does that, it can look
at the size of the receiver
and know how far it should
throw the ball to it.
This is Terabyte and
it's our running back.
It's really great at finding
the gap to go down the field
and get a touchdown.
Irish Chocolate is one of our linebackers
and it makes a lot of really
great open-field tackles.
This is Justin Unit and it's our kicker.
It can accurately kick the
ball between two and 60 feet.
This is one of the most
precise robots on our team.
(Celebratory music)
- [Narrator] Notre Dame
competes against three other
Midwest colleges in a
tournament held each spring,
but it takes a full school year
to prepare for that gauntlet.
In the fall semester, the
team recruits new members
and trains them for a one-off scrimmage
with another college's team.
This year, their fall opponent
is Valparaiso University,
and they're not leaving
anything to chance.
In the week before the game,
they're running practice drills,
they're learning the playbook,
and they're watching tape,
just like any other football team.
- [Brendan] This is
basically the culmination
of all this work you've put in in the shop
with these robots, building them,
repairing them, designing them.
And you're going out
and basically watching
your engineering put to the test.
Irish on three.
One, two, three.
- [Team] Irish.
(applauding)
(upbeat music)
- [Zoe] The rules of robotic
football are very similar
to that of human football,
so we follow NCAA rules
to the best of our ability.
There are two 20 minute halves for a game,
with a 10 minute half time,
so it's a very quick-paced game.
(cheering)
- [Team] Yes. There we go.
- [Zoe] These robots
take a lot of big hits
(robots crashing)
- We have a backup for every robot,
just in case one breaks down.
(yelling)
- [Announcer] This cannot be good.
- [Zoe] So, if the quarterback breaks down
and we pull it off and put
the second-string one in,
and the pit-crew will work on it
and try and fix it as quickly as possible.
(suspenseful music)
- [Narrator] With their starting
quarterback back in the game
after a quick medical
break, the Robotic Irish
fight to hold their narrow
lead but can't score.
A touchdown and an extra point
will snatch victory from Notre Dame.
- [Team] This is the
game, this is the game.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Got it, got it, got it, got it.
(Cheering)
- [Zoe] The goal of this
is to grow it to be a truly
national competition, where we can have
multiple conferences
competing for the trophy.
- [Narrator] One day, this
could be a real sport,
or maybe it already is.
- [Team] Irish on three.
One, two, three.
Irish.
- [Brendan] This is
basically real football,
it's just not humans playing it.
(suspenseful music)